If you want to hear how a character from Unbreakable,
Split and Glass also appears in The Village,
then stick around to the end of this video.
[INTRO]
Welcome to Things You Missed, today I'll be
covering one of my favorite movies of all
time, The Village.
If you haven't seen it, I recommend you watch
it first because you definitely don't want
to spoil this one for yourself.
This thing is such a masterpiece and in the
broadest sense, it's a story about the dangers
of sheltering oneself.
The village elders were each scarred by the
horrible things that happened in the outside
world, so they created the isolated village
in the Covington Woods to keep themselves
safe from the heartbreak they endured in modern
society.
But after some time, their sheltering of themselves
kept leading them to then back to that same
heartbreak.
They were blind to the fact that their new
society was becoming the very reason for their
suffering, and it would ironically take someone
who is literally blind to help them see the
solution.
So in today's episode, I'm also giving the
gift of sight, so that you can see a few Things
You Missed.
[Things You Missed]
The opening scene is the perfect example of
how backwards the state of affairs in the
Village has become.
The entire community mourns the death of a
young boy, the son of one of the village elders.
We later find out that the reason for his
death is because the village lacks any kind
of medicine, and the elders have sworn an
oath never to leave the confines of the village.
A clue about the secret held by the elders
can be found very close to the beginning of
the movie.
"You may run from sorrow as we have.
Sorrow will find you.”
Nobody is allowed to step foot beyond the
barrier.
They enforce this rule through the use of
legends.
The legends of the monsters in the woods surrounding
the village draw inspiration from the idea
of legends in real life.
All throughout history, parents have made
up and passed down stories to get their children
to behave.
In this case, Those We Do Not Speak Of from
The Village are very similar to the monsters
that ancient cartographers used to use to
discourage sailors from exploring unknown
areas of the seas.
We even see a similar kind of warning painted
on a rock at the edge of the village.
Some of the legends are based on real things.
The idea of the creatures in the woods was
spawned by actual rumors in the area…
"There did exist rumors of creatures in these
woods, it is in one of the history books I
used to teach in the towns..."
...and the practice of marking the doors with
red paint is pulled from the religious story
of Passover, where the Israelites homes where
marked with lamb’s blood thus were passed
over by the plague of death of the first born.
There are other psychological tactics employed
to keep people in the village through the
use of fear.
They've gone to great lengths to cover the
village in the color yellow, which they call
the protective color.
They rid the village of any reds, because
the settlement is placed in the center of
a large outgrowth of red berries.
By conditioning the young to associate the
color red with the monsters, they create a
sense of danger for anyone who leaves the
village.
That's why Ivy is a perfect hero.
Ivy is blind, and therefore, will not be scared
by the color red.
There is a running theme in director M Night
Shyamalan's movies where those who are impaired
are stronger in some unforeseen way.
We see it in Elijah and Kevin from the Eastrail
Trilogy, the Hess family in Signs and Nana
and Pop Pop from The Visit.
There's also a strong link between The Village
and Shyamalan's 2013 film After Earth.
In The Village Luscious theorizes that the
creatures sense emotion and fear, and later
Ivy believes she can pass through the woods
because she has no fear.
In After Earth, there are these monsters called
Ursas, who like Ivy are blind, but are able
to detect pheromones that the human body dispels
when experiencing fear.
But perhaps the story that most closely ties
in with The Village is the story from Unbreakable,
Split and Glass.
Each has three main characters.
In The Village, we have Noah, who is mentally
ill but physically strong; Ivy, who is physically
impaired by her blindness, but mentally strong;
and Lucius, who is physically strong and mentally
strong.
The characters in the Eastrail trilogy fill
the same roles: Kevin is mentally ill but
physically strong, Elijah is physically broken
but mentally a genius, and David Dunn is mentally
and physically strong.
Lucius and David Dunn even share the trait
of being the strong silent type; both characters
rarely up their mouths.
There's one more link that possibly puts these
movies literally in the same universe.
One signature of M Night Shyamalan, is that
he almost always makes a cameo appearance
in his movies.
In Unbreakable, Split, and Glass, he plays
one character named Jai, an IT guy responsible
for setting up security cameras who appears
in all three films.
In The Village, he cameos as the guy reading
the newspaper at the security hut, where his
name is also Jai.
"Hey Jai, where's the maintenance ladder?"
Maybe this means that all four films take
place in the same universe together.
Or that he just likes the name Jai.
We’ll probably never know for sure.
One thing we do know that M Night loves is
Philadelphia.
Eleven of his 13 films take place there, and
if you pay close attention, The Village is
one of them.
Mr. Walker mentions that he once taught history
at the University of Pennsylvania, which is
located in Philly.
...and the newspaper seen when Ivy leaves
to woods to retrieve supplies is the Philadelphia
Journal.
The date seen on the newspaper is also the
same as the movie’s release date, July 30th
2004.
And if you look at the articles in this newspaper,
they are almost all tragic headlines, which
ties in with the idea of the elders wanting
to escape the horrors of the real world and
start their own society in the woods.
One of the reasons that Ivy’s father is
comfortable with sending her is that she is
visually blind, and she won’t be able to
convey the secrets of the real world when
she returns.
Even the escorts that set out with her are
instructed not to venture past the road, so
that she would be the only one to go over
the wall and into the outside world.
The wall that she climbs over is covered in
vines of ivy, like all great walls are, and
her name is literally Ivy Walker.
She is the only one to go over the wall.
It is also fitting that she be the one to
go, because the wildlife preserve that they
are secretly living on was owned by her grandfather
before his death.
Ivy is blind, but she is able to sense a certain
color that people give off that only her and
her father can sense, and when Lucius is stabbed
by Noah, she is no longer able to sense his
color because he was dying.
"I cannot see his color."
You could say that one major theme of the
movie is that it is the things we don’t
see that are most significant.
The villagers don’t see what really lies
beyond their community, the elders don’t
see that they have become the very thing they
ran from and Ivy does not see when she’s
holding the color red, which is used to scare
the people away from ever trying to leave
the woods.
This theme is also reflected in the cinematography.
We end up looking away from many of the most
significant events.
From Ivy and Lucius’s first kiss…
to Noah’s attack on Lucius…
To the appearance of Noah in the woods, dressed
as the monster to try to kill Ivy, where our
view is obstructed and we’re forced to rely
on our other senses to track to the monster.
Now if he really had balls, he would have
just made the whole movie black… or maybe
that’s overkill.
Or maybe it’s a good podcast idea.
Click the video on the left for the entire
144 Things You Missed in Shyamalan’s Eastrail
177 trilogy, and if you love horror then remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week.
Ring that deathbell for notifications and
I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.